voilà la chaîne qui va représenter les
femelle labrador au salon de
l'agriculture en espérant faire un
résultat mais c'est pas le plus
important
plus important c'est déjà d'avoir été
sélectionné par des spécialistes de race
donc des juges qui eux mêmes élèves la
casse depuis plusieurs années et c'est
le cas de philippe l'ins un belge
installé depuis une quinzaine d'années
en centre val de loire pour y élever des
golden retriever quid des labradors à
pied ici pas de commerces à outrance
l'éleveur recherchent l'excellence et la
pureté de la race
pour chacun de ces animaux ce juge
internationale des concours de beauté ou
de travail a d'ailleurs choisi la
sologne pour redonner à ses retrievers
un environnement adapté à ma race qui a
été un travail travail est élevé pour
faire du rapport en fait après la chasse
donc quand nous tend l'oiseau est tombé
bon c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
d'être en sologne mais c'est surtout
pour la beauté et du territoire c'est
magnifique
bon moi je vis en belgique allez je
vivais en belgique mais on n'a pas des
territoires comme ça en bétique
d'ailleurs au salon de l'agriculture
philippe la mince a promis de porter
deux casquettes défenseur des races
retriever et promoteur de la sologne